meilleur fédéraux ski qui a écrit
Poutine et l'Ukraine les faces cachées
alors ça tombe à point hauteur de
plusieurs livres diplomates vous avez
été au première loge vous avez été tout
près de bregenèves vous avez été avec
Gorbat shop la pérestroika et tout ça
monsieur fédération est content de vous
parler
c'est normal situation parce que j'ai
l'impression que toute ma vie est
bousillé parce que mon père était un
grand ukrainien grand-père de la guerre
continue dans ma famille il y a 11
personnes qui ont péri à Stalingrad
notamment et puis toute mon action
diplomatique est détruite nous avons
construit un monde sur aujourd'hui on
assiste une nouvelle guerre froide
empire parce que vous comprenez pendant
les garçons il y avait les règles
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de règles et
on assiste un clivage en deux bloc il y
aura un clivage d'une part
occidentale Poutine renforcer la
cohésion accidental et le temps à
renforcé en quelque sorte Poutine la
poussière dans les bras de la Chine
alors le Chine
la Russie il y aura un bloc en
occidental éventuellement avec les reins
tout ça c'est ça me rend triste et je
suis et vous dites et vous venez de le
dire
que c'est pire que lors de la guerre
froide parce que justement il n'y a plus
de règles on ne sait plus il y a plus de
carte routière on est dans l'inconnu
total
bien sûr
de sécurité européenne avec Mitterrand
autrefois avec les Américains et tout
était détruit au fur et à mesure tout ça
ça
préfigure quelque chose de très
dangereux en plus ce que est très grave
vous ne ressentez pas mais comme je suis
professionnel de la diplomatie vous
comprenez pendant la guerre froide il y
avait la propagande mais il y avait à
côté il y avait la politique réelle qui
était menée par les gens hyper
professionnel
et finalement aujourd'hui ils n'ont
seulement il n'y a pas de règle
tout ça c'est
désastreux désastreux c'est très très
grave et nous n'avons pas beaucoup
d'instruments je tiens à vous dire
gravement vous savez il y a trois
solutions je tiens à vous dire gravement
il y a la solution de la Guerre mondiale
avec les armes atomiques ce qui n'est
pas exclure parce que vous savez il n'y
a plus de dialogue il n'y a plus de
contact et les gens prennent les
décisions à la base erronée il y a les
sanctions
les sanctions j'ai beaucoup étudié même
je tiens à vous dire que les sanctions
ne devront pas à mon sens le résultat
que vous pensez parce que vous comprenez
les Russes ils ont vécu dis-moi 10 fois
moins bien sur le signe autrefois ils
vont perdre la moitié de leur pouvoir
d'achat améliorer un transformation de
l'économie il y a une sorte d'économie
de mobilisation dans le style néo
stalinien c'est grave pour les Russes
mais il y aura des répercussions sur
l'Occident le prix en flambés il y aura
en Europe ça va coûter 10 fois plus cher
le gaz choc pétrolier bref tout ça c'est
très difficile à prévoir et il y a une
solution que je soutiens beaucoup à
titre personnel c'est une solution de
formater d'un côté et de l'autre côté
solution
de Soco président Macron appelle une
longue difficile chemin de désescalade
et moi je souligne ça et même je viens
vous faire boucher je suis écrivain
maintenant
d'origine à la fois
ukrainien et russe je tiens à faire un
appel vraiment appel à une rencontre
immédiate entre le président
zzinski et
président Poutine parce que vous
comprenez les contacts des centres sur
walterne je sais pas mon expérience je
ne donne pas les choses nécessaires
pour parler mais si Monsieur Poutine
arrive en disant d'abord vous n'êtes pas
un vrai pays je considère que que tu
dois avoir un changement de régime parce
qu'il a déjà traité de régime nazi que
peut que peut donner Poutine à zilenski
pour que les deux sauvent la face
moi je considère qu'il y a une base de
négociation vous comprenez président il
a parlé de statut notre de l'Ukraine et
Poutine dans le contexte actuel il a
toujours proclamé que il ne veut pas
occuper le crème que ce sera une mission
de course durée et vous comprenez ce
qu'il faut éviter
les Russes dans leur four intérieur ils
ont perdu 27 millions des gens dans la
lutte contre les nazis ils sont contre
la guerre et ils ne vont pas accepter
les choses en plus il y a une chose très
grave aujourd'hui est-ce que vous pensez
que Monsieur Poutine est-ce que vous
pensez monsieur Poutine reculerait
si zilenskid Zeb on va très bien je vous
promets que jamais l'Ukraine ne fera
partie de l'OTAN est-ce qu'on est pas
déjà dépasser ça
non vous savez il n'y a pas
d'alternative et je conseille vraiment
c'est pour ça que je soutiens beaucoup
plus en Macron qui parle au téléphone
hier il a parlé 1h30 avec Poutine encore
une fois et je le soutiens beaucoup plus
qu'en France les gens beaucoup ne
comprennent pas ça mais nous n'avons pas
beaucoup d'instruments la situation est
très grave moi j'aime beaucoup cette
ville Kiev mais si demain il y a les
combats dans dans la rue de Kiev c'est
une chose gravissime il y aura beaucoup
de paires des Russes des des Ukrainiens
ça me déchire complètement et
franchement personne n'a l'entrée parce
que
les Russes les Russes soutient Poutine
soyons très clair parce que les Russes
ils ont l'impression pour l'instant mais
quand il y a des pertes c'est la
situation peut changer c'est pour ça je
dis immédiatement la rencontre avec
entre poutian et ski encore
bois pour négocier un retrait des troupe
russe encore une voix pour trouver un
accord en Ukraine et la Russie
bien sûr nous n'avons pas beaucoup de
solutions autrement on va tout
simplement faire une des postures parce
qu'on comprenait dire et qu'on soutien
le peuple crânien et le faire ne rien
faire c'est pas suffisant la Guerre
mondiale il faut l'éviter
c'est une chose qui nous donnera pas en
plus je suis inquiet pour l'Europe
franchement je veux regarder la bourse
aussi
j'ai une question pour vous qui
connaissez bien les arcanes du pouvoir à
Moscou et tout ça est-ce que avec les
sanctions qui sont quand même sans
précédent là c'est beaucoup plus qu'en
2014 avec la Crimée est-ce que Poutine
lui-même pour être menacé par les
oligarques qui lui dirait bon mais
savez-vous on n'a pas envie de perdre
des milliards par jour
non non non
les Russes détestent les oligares et
vous comprenez l'alternative à Poutine
Sylviana c'est pas du tout les
procédantaux il faut pas vivre dans le
monde imaginaire vous comprenez les
chevaux les Russes ils attendent
aujourd'hui c'est une sorte de
crispation moi je suis bouleversé parce
qu'il y a des problèmes de problèmes
avec les libertés de la presse il y a
cette station éco de Moscou aujourd'hui
qui est interdit tout ça c'est une chose
il ne faut pas qu'on rêve mais en même
temps à ce qu'il faut éviter c'est
maintenant surtout les fusions du sang
et après comprendre que la passation
imaginaire de Poutine sera beaucoup plus
facile vous savez j'étais on a réussi de
sortir du communisme comment parce que
il n'y avait pas de confrontation un
conseil essayons d'autres maintenant
dans l'immédiat les fusion du sang et
après je suis certain que j'étais
combattant pour la démocratie que tôt ou
tard lors de la démocratie viendra aussi
en Russie quand quand vous entendez
Vladimir federovski ancien diplomate
auteur russe c'est même écrit plusieurs
livres dont un sur qui m'intrigue que je
vais aller trouver vous dites la vraie
histoire du Docteur Jivago de pasternac
alors vous avez rien
de se replonger d'un docteur Jivago et
dans le vôtre Vladimir merci beaucoup
fédéraux merci de nous avoir
mon affection pour le Canada très bien
Sidi merci au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI